Eataly embark on an adventure to the  world's most exquisite destination  a place of preserved history  incomparable beauty and unparalleled  tranquility  I saw midday grow green blends right  into the Italian architecture  [Music]  it was the polar cafe  exactly when you try to show hot country  yeah we probably could he used to warm  up mission  look sir four-point Asia Oh Mia right  here I'm coming to you  [Applause]  [Applause]  sorry for yelling  [Music]  no no no the damage also did you want to  get out and compare or should we maybe  think about going yeah let's go  this holiday season  stop your adventure in eat  [Music]  [Music]  you  [Music]  you